hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights of [ __ ]
boys time again for another shot
I can't believe this shot number five
already man I bet like I don't know how
much longer is in this game but holy
hell this game is going on for a good
long bit I mean if there's even one more
episode we're already we're at the point
where the other ones would end but I
don't feel like we're near the end by
all I got a few more to go but god I've
been loving it anyway whatever dude whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay alright okay so
my next objective is I was farming up a
whole bunch like a whole bunch in
preparation for what I'm about to do
which is unlock the next balloon boy and
buy my new upgrades so this one is over
y'all the new sorting hat is by the exit
protection hat number C so I imagine
that he's probably tougher well the
first thing I need to do because I know
how this works now is I need to get my
defense up and then immediately be
prepared to heal myself why is spread
bomb there's only one of me why would
you do that okay my defenses up now and
that's actually gonna really help me to
nail this guy to the wall yeah this one
yeah sorry I'm like I'm like totally
scatterbrained then again I have out a
lot of shots by now why is spread bomb
stop doing that my defense didn't do
anything oh my god I'm gonna die why
don't I have more than a large pizza I
need to double large pizza this time you
son of a [ __ ] ah god damn am you is
there like a phantom bolt lunge phantom
healing again story
it's not really what I wanted but I
guess a good help because 25% is gonna
be more than what where is it more ah
it's not more it's just about the same
okay but either way I can put him on the
robes with this and then I'll be able to
at least keep them off guard and that
would mean that I'd be able to hammer
into it more I don't know why this is so
technical I just want him to be up there
lose balance that's all I wanted yeah
yeah yeah yep
this piddly damage hardly doing anything
not really doing much at all oh you
don't get it cool okay so now that I got
that I can hopefully I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to paralyze it that seems
like a thing that's probably not gonna
happen huh no it never paralyzes him
like what's even the problem of doing it
well he regained his balance so that's
good I guess so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna double pizza again that was only
five oh five why was that less damage
than he normally does I guess I
shouldn't complain you know what I'm
just gonna I'm gonna keep connection
again cuz hopefully that's gonna finish
him off okay I got this in the bag oh
that's right he was using spread bomb
got my memories going I'm probably
losing my mind
I've been losing my mind since I got
infected by Slenderman and slender the
arrival and I lost my mind in those
mines I was replaced at that point and
no one was the wiser okay but either way
I hopefully have a lot I'll buy your
[ __ ] cuz I got nothing there we go extra
large says that's what I wanted okay
that's a lot better
okay that's a lot better yeah that's a
lot better I don't I don't even know why
I'm gonna get that but sure I'm gonna
get it and to be fat to be honest I
don't want to replace my lucky soda
because my lucky soda is what's getting
me good
okay so what I might be able to do
actually is I might be able to sell my
other large pizzas I don't get a lot
back yeah that's like one enemy so I
guess it's not that big a deal
but it could sell once I replace
everything my old parts and then that
would allow me to do just a little bit
better and then stay with lucky soda
because they don't need anything else
okay
now I'll be able to sell this back get
some tokens and then I'll be able to
move forward to the next boss possibly
but then again I don't really know about
that because frankly I'm way under the
level of what I'm supposed to be and I
have eleven pieces of tape why do I have
eleven pieces of tape yeah might be
useful there are some things like in
five nights at Freddy's five nights at
fuckboys two that I wasn't supposed to
sell because it's gonna be bad I didn't
even know why that's a thing now I just
need to make sure that I have a lot of
extra-large crap you know what I mean
I'm five shots deep it's not going well
for me okay I need to how much health
business oh it does all that's beautiful
okay good thing I didn't get rid of my
large because I would need them at some
point okay alright cool cool cool yes
that's exactly what I needed that's
perfect I can beat anybody now I can
probably beat Freddy
probably not but oh I almost forgot
about the puppet here I was just pulling
up foxy by pulling on me if you if you
know what I'm getting at you get what
I'm saying that joke I fireball that's a
lot of you scream oh why do you even
bother thank you thank you thank you I
don't need to kill you anymore you do
literally nothing for me oh come on you
you're getting so now I can move forward
I can go you yeah actually
aw dammit I wish I wouldn't I wish I
wouldn't have done that I wanted to see
if I could fight the puppet to see how
tough he really was he's probably very
tough
let me be Freddie first before I get to
that Oh also I didn't mention this but I
did this I discovered this I was trying
to unlock this and I somehow I put the
poster back up and I could punch it a
bunch but that was originally in 5-2
fuckboys one that was what you did to
get the dragon bill though quite he
doesn't seem to be working for me
because I punched it a lot off-camera
just to see if it would get it to me and
it did not so I don't know what's up
with that it is what it is now the other
thing that I don't know is I don't know
where the hell Barney's I'm not Freddie
maybe I need to kill Freddie first and
then I'm gonna be able to do whatever
you want me to do so let's try that
because I got Freddie like right off the
bat of this thing so it's entirely
possible that if I kill Freddie which is
entirely impossible because I'm way
under level for him but let's just find
out because frankly I gotta get through
this game or else I'm not gonna last the
night I'm going to good yes I am do that
that's a good idea
oh he looks so scary I actually tried to
fight him before I remember that now
okay so I need to yes
fortify and then what are all these
things backup - that's right I just need
to back up oh that's oh that's bad
that's right you do - oh whoa oh god I
did a backup successful backup ass and
that's all it did oh my god I'm so bored
okay what I need is I don't to waste my
Gooden so
[Music]
ow okay I should have used my Gooden
I should have used my Gooden oh I should
have used my Gooden oh I'm so cold now
I'm gonna die yes upon me I've got
plenty of them why don't I use them it's
such a dingus over the place for you
bastards I'm so ready for you come on
come on come on come on come on okay I
know what I'm gonna do I know what I
need to do I know what I need to do I
need to do a lot of this stuff cuz he's
gonna hit me hard but that's okay
oh you didn't need to be hard at all oh
damn that did it couldn't found it
damage
oh I love that I love it okay spread
bomb that's okay I can take that that's
not even worse than the other spread
bomb that I was dealing with from the
Hat what are you you're Jay wimp this
guy's no wimp
I was just playing it not correctly
before preemptively gonna use oh no oh
no okay this might be bad oh oh it
didn't work you're such a dingus it
didn't work at all your plan failed
okay perfect is great this is great I
like this
ah let me try to stun you it never works
but I'm gonna try anyway
boys see my eyeballs get out of here
come on bring it on where's the hard
stuff
shut up Amy maybe I do just do two in a
row
oh no no no no no don't do that no no no
no don't no no or not no oh yeah yeah
oh no no damn it ah [ __ ] if I die from
this I'm gonna be so pissed I'm gonna
die from this
he's gonna do something oh god good good
good good yes yes
oh it's works out so beautifully you're
such up I'll inhale nothing that I don't
want to inhale even though I was just
talking about all the dongs that I was
healing that's that's on my time it's
not you that poison me oh come on you're
almost dead oh what's that you are dead
I've gotten pretty tough
right now if you couldn't tell I'm so
good at things I'm so great forty-four
thousand now right now the only problem
is I have no idea how to get money done
cuz I got the thing that I needed i
fashioned dad let's talk more let's kill
Bonnie got a secret report
oh boy mo reading learn phantom stinger
they don't know what that dude is that
gonna poison the people that I need to
be poisoned room 3 oh that's oh that's
right it wasn't named her one of the
locks on the door dropped to the ground
with a crank
yes I have oh there was no phantom
Bonnie oh that's right Oh give me pardon
me sorry my being here without a blade
the gap wait yes with Bonnie okay so I
yes I do
cuz I'm Bonnie too to the fence why
didn't I do that ever in the first place
you could literally just stay in the
office when you drop in okay fine you
can do it your way then you British
spring-trap lucky pizza yes yes yes yes
yes make gold drop more gold well I
don't have any gold it's not gonna it's
tokens I don't know what you're talking
about I don't know what you're putting
I'm not putting up what you're putting
down I don't I don't get what you're
flipping I don't I'm not I'm not your
home skillet
I don't understand I'm emotionally
compromised I don't understand okay so
do I need to farm more or something or
is Bonnie I'm just not gonna go all
right then I guess that's that I have no
idea maybe I should fight the puppet
maybe I should okay so I guess I need to
start from the beginning of the
beginning of the thing get out of my
face you bastards I think I need to
start at the beginning of the vents and
then work up from there but I might just
let the puppet come after me oh do I
have enough items for that I tried to
warn you you got [ __ ] up I was trying
to be on your side but you're just like
no I know I'm a party hat alpha male oh
please
me and then my fault
okay so I think I have enough items I
might let the puppet come get me
I'm get out of here why why do you want
to die so badly okay this is a point of
no return once you enter you will not be
able to fight any of the bonus bonus
bosses bonus bosses I don't know what
that means what we talking about board
is bought him bonus soda I don't
understand
I you can't just say that to me is there
like something is it like in the arcade
baby died already geez get out of my
face oh no damage really no damn it how
about all the damage ba ba ba ba bo I
might just hang around till the public
indefinitely how about I do just that
I'm gonna hang around till the Bubba
comes after me so I'm gonna stand right
up on his face just be like hey what you
gonna do y'all miss Mae ain't nobody
gonna mess with me I'm on massive with
the ball I'm on mess with a bowl I'm on
a met bag oh yeah get your game on go
play I don't think that's a right words
to this song now it's track okay shits
about to go down come on baby
this has been the longest two minutes of
my life I mean jeez I'm so tired of this
baloney but let me say before that so I
can like if this doesn't work out then
whatever but if it does work out and I'm
close then I can fight him right again
Jesus what the hell man oh hey how's it
going hey the puppet a yeah being a bit
of it he's almost dead I'm gonna never
have to worry about this [ __ ] again
oh yes i evaded it you bastard puppet oh
come on I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna scream
in your face like oh you hear that
scream yes I did it I did that I did the
thing I did it whoa hey I finally killed
you get good that's what I am is Oh what
my words exactly what what why why is he
harder now why that's not allowed
[Music]
that's such baloney and you know it I
put out all the effort to beat your ass
into the ground and that's how you repay
me
what oh-ho okay so what I'm gonna do now
is I need to go back and I need to buy
more items from the last balloon boy and
then I guess I need to go into the vents
because I got nothing else to do besides
that so it's my only option with all
five in hand and both gatekeepers dead
the seal shall be broken and inside
you'll be led now that's an interesting
statement because I have all the five
shards and it says both gatekeepers so
it's not talking about the phantom
things now my idea is the puppet came
and I don't know if he came back in the
other ones but he came back so
considering it saying there's two
gatekeepers and now apparently there's
two puppets
maybe if I kill the other one the seal
shall be broken and inside I will be led
that's my idea cuz yeah okay so that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna try what
what what do you oh you didn't
understand okay I thought something was
happening don't just say what like that
I need to understand that I'm being I'm
just doing it to understand that I'm
understanding you and also shut up okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna camp
out again and I'm gonna try to beat this
bastard at one more time because why not
I am so good at games and stuff yeah
alright you guys it's almost a vers I
don't know if he's gonna be like
astronomically harder or something I
don't see why he would because feasibly
beating these guys before going into the
vent and maybe like I might be totally
wrong in this but I have a feeling I'm
right that there's gonna be hard but the
last one after I was using all my items
it wasn't actually get hard so we'll see
we're good on we're good on you get a
jump scare me again why come on what do
you got Billy boo yeah whoa I don't
think oh that is nasty that is a nasty
attack jeez that is disgusting okay so I
always got to make sure that I always
use an extra large beats on my second
one it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
alright we're okay and this is gonna
take a while
good thing I got lots of items oh why is
he enraged
why is he enraged and rage doesn't sound
good I don't like that I don't like
whatever that is I don't like what just
happened
you know I'm at reddit that doesn't
sound good
oh god please don't kill me
ah well how the hell am I gonna do what
I need to do
alright you know what my new strategy's
gonna be I'm gonna back up bash this
[ __ ] until I get a backup crit oh yes
Breann I don't think there's any way
okay I really don't think there's any
way I've tried this like ten times now
and a backup bash hit but it didn't do a
lot of damage so okay alright okay
all right here's the deal I tried it a
lot I tried a lot of very strategies I
tried D buffing and buffing myself I
tried everything that I can do to make
it work and unfortunately I don't think
it's possible like I really don't know
how it would be possible because when he
enrages he also can like normally do a
triple hit and just totally annihilate
me so there's like nothing else so I
feel bad but I got a progress in the
game like I can't be hung up on this
because I don't even know what I'm
supposed to do this is slow and okay
what okay I don't know what's happening
right now I'm not entirely sure what's
going on room 15a
oh that's right the vents were named by
room okay all right this is fine I guess
and why am i doing it I don't need to go
back that way I need to get to the
office
so the idea Oh what is this whoa hey
what the hell is that fence security
system well that's an engine block what
is that okay well here we go I guess I
don't know how to anticipate this take
that yeah oh god you're strong why are
you so strong
what well they all is that
what's going on huh
[Music]
there we go
get back here you [ __ ] don't get away
from me and your stupid security system
okay so does it like not hurt me at all
is that what I'm supposed to take from
this it's got a buttload of Health
okay just poison all right ain't bad at
all
but just to play it safe you never know
what it's gonna do
baby I did nothing okay
oh that's right I attack first oh wow
that hurts hard
okay fine though I got it I got it under
wraps as long as you don't kill me I'll
be fine just don't blow me don't be to
blow me so hard
[Music]
god damn it okay I'll figure this out
the next time I play this game which
will be real soon not for you guys it'll
be a day later but for me it'll be right
away so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the antics with more
fire bytes for more stuff that I've done
and as always I will see you
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
[Music]